[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
dreamers cosplayers artists tournament
organizers and all of our players you
are for honor hello
I'm Ramon Campos Iola creative director
whether it be upgraded stability with
the dedicated servers release of Heroes
constant balancing and new training
tools we would not be here without your
passion and commitment you've helped us
enrich the experience thank you but
actions speak louder than words right in
celebration of III we are inviting new
players to join so if you haven't played
foreigner yet now is your chance
starting today and until next Monday we
are giving away the PC starter edition
on you play download it this week on PC
and it's yours for free
[Applause]
join the fight with us
[Music]
but that's not all because building on
everything that we've learned we are now
ready to expand our world
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
casting shadow waiting for the turn
something is calm
in
classroom
[Applause]
[Music]
No
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
after the great Cataclysm that brought
Knights Vikings and samurai to fight
civil war consume China warriors of the
Wulin factions fought each other but
failed to establish order amid the chaos
for warriors of the ruling no March West
with the new faction four new fighters
visual enhancements and single-player
concerns yet to be revealed the marching
fire update is our biggest and most
ambitious edition so far but this update
would not be complete without answering
a huge request from our community a new
44 multiplayer mode fulfilling the
classic medieval fantasy know what it is
the castle siege so please allow me to
introduce you to this new mode bridge
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]